hello this video german severn okay
let's see Queens gambit yeah one of the
absolute main lines nowadays all the
Queens gambit 94 this is a move that I I
wanted to study for quite a while and
never really gotten around to doing it
and now I get it played it played
against me I wanted to study this study
it for black actually hmm okay he really
wants to wants to annoy me on the King
side hmm yeah my bishop is in some some
some danger here yeah okay I wonder if
it is so easy for him to take it no
actually takes de 95 f 4 takes takes
Queen g4 check should work so okay I
don't understand the plan that black has
to be perfectly frank of what is your
point isn't this just quite weakening
even Queen age 5 comes into comes into
consideration
maybe maybe do that
g on g 5 is a liability i wonder if i
should just play h form hmm interesting
but that's not opening up the positioner
and i want to open this up g for you and
g4s better wow very quickly played but
the rock is strapped right there should
be two loop chick screen f2 I can check
and maybe play Queen f4 at the end hmm
well you know man this isn't really
really that important i guess if i go
here i can do this first and then see
what I'm playing I can also take on g5
with the pawn which is just good I mean
k rool maybe Queen to have seven but
then i can trade and and trap the rook
ok yeah so if it takes III I'll grab g5
threatening g6 and on Queen f7 out rate
and play Queen after breaking f2 to trap
the rook
well as usual I'm getting totally
ignored so g 6 m isn't that kind of
dangerous thinking now okay but you 86
home so he had an idea with this move
and i can go look see 20 gauge too but
that's not ideal okay okay then i should
have played King f2 I mean that was I
just wanted to have it more convenient
kf2 was trapping the rook immediately I
just thought that g6 is easier but ok
Bishop I 6 is very stupid and that's
wrong I mean overlooking busia basics or
ignoring it is pretty stupid
so let's see
I know you can take on g6 with a pawn
I'm such an idiot I should take age 7
first ok didn't didn't react to this
video check I think he could have taken
on g6 looked a bit bit awkward
oh yeah how exactly am i winning here
don't don't see a direct Wayne ok now
I'm now 28 is not even a real threat but
that covers the g6 porn time morning
maybe Queen to g5 is interesting trying
to highly resolve this position with the
rook
yeah I mean I still check those those
pawns seven check check check check
maybe those pawns promote right black
resigns yeah I was badly playin I mean
the game should be just over a little
bit after this but I just played it very
sloppy fashion yeah okay this is and now
just King F to end game over which I saw
when I thought okay well whatever yeah I
didn't think of this Seto what I was
thinking b6 the idea was that if i take
that he has his check that was my
thought and of course the idea is just
bishop a six I thought I can do this and
well again be very convenient about
things the straps look I saw that but I
thought well we can do whatever yeah
quite stupid anyway okay okay it seems
that ok this is this is totally winning
very nice threatening I didn't think of
castles of course very nice ok so I
didn't even make a mistake with just six
just yeah I didn't didn't see why I
didn't make a mistake ok this one he
could have played this and now we get
five and things I totally had clear
check here I'm even worse we have kind
of falling apart here g5 for just this
week
and this this was a huge mistake he
could have taken this now Black is
totally fine china I'm probably better
again no computer actually disagrees oh
that's interesting I was still I think a
three that I thought that this should be
still a pretty clear win for white
objectively i mean i thought okay i can
certainly screw it up because it's just
complicated but i thought objectively it
should be some wind with those pawns but
the computer actually points out the
clear draw with this and this is yeah
this is a bit tough okay this happened
no one I'm winning again check check
check check check yeah it's nice
something like this check is the
checkmate is the outcome okay hope you
like the game was entertaining thanks
for watching